那我也不知道你今天过得怎么样
但我猜可能或许有那么一点点累
对吧有些时候
我觉得生活可能像一条长长的路
就是咱们一边走啊
一边看着身边的人
有的跑得快对吧
有的走得远
可能不知不觉我们自己就慌了
然后很多人就开始怀疑自己
哎呀我是不是走的太慢了呀
或者是我是不是不够好
可其实我觉得很多的一些焦虑
并不是因为我们做的不够
而是因为
我们总是在拿别人的节奏来衡量自己
而真正能够让我们安稳下来的
我觉得从来都不是外界的这种掌声
或者是比较
而是那一句轻声的确认
我知道我在做什么
那么今天我也想陪大家一起聊一聊
如何把这个注意力收回来
就是学会啊
我们和自己在一起
那么也许这些话不会改变什么大事
但我觉得能够在今天
至少让我们能够轻一点
对吧松一口气
那么在今天的直播开始之前
大家可以在评论区留下此刻的心情
也让我知道
对吧现在的你正在经历一些什么啊
我不知道有没有这种经历
就做了一件事
结果不如意
立刻就开始责怪自己
哎呀早知道这样我就不该这么做
你看我果然还是不行
那这种现象在心理学有一个名字
叫做后视偏差
大家可以打一打这四个字来
后视偏差
后视镜啊
什么意思呢
就是当事情已经发生了
我们的大脑就会根据结果
去篡改你的记忆
以为对吧
咱们自己当时早就该看到这些迹象
于是很多人就开始否定过去的自己
可事实是什么
没有人能够真正的准确的还原过去
因为当时的你
就是凭着当时拥有的条件
对吧当时有限的经验
做出了你觉得最合理的选择呀
也许结果不完美
但那并不代表你愚蠢
更不代表你该被责怪
所以大家记住
过去的你不是你的敌人
相反
他是你一路走到今天的朋友啊
是过去的你
帮你跨过了那些不眠的夜晚
让你在一个个的分叉口上
哪怕迷茫
也能勇敢的走下去
所以
别再用今天的认知去霸凌当时的自己
你要知道
没有那个曾经的你
就没有今天的你啊
学会和过去的自己和解
你会发现每一次的失败都不是错误
而是通向成长的必经之路
所以记住
永远不要贬低当时的自己
因为那个你
我相信他已经足够勇敢了
我们曾经说过
过去的你并不应该被苛责
而是值得被感谢
我知道
我们很多人其实就是放不下这种自责
陷在后悔和反复的思考里边
白白消耗了自己
是吧
我不知道你有没有这种时候
眼前想一堆
结果呢
越想越乱
第二天更没力气真正拉开距离的
拉开差距的
我告诉大家
不是多想
而是你能不能停下来
所以我想跟大家聊一聊
就是
当一个人陷入到这种过度思考的时候
我们有什么样的方法
可以把自己拉回来
那
欢迎来到松明讲心理的这么一个频道
那可能有的同学是第一次来
第一次来的同学可
以加一加宋明老师的这么一个关注
如果说觉得我们每一天早晨
给大家分享的这些心理学
对于你来说真的帮助你成长了
加一加咱们的粉丝团好不好啊
每位同学可以帮宋明老师点点赞
也可以分享一下
宋明讲心理的这么一个直播间啊
嗯
哼
我太难过了
带孩子回国了
可是他在美国更肆无忌惮了
他开心的很哈哈哈
hmm
我怀疑他是NPD
多来听听我们的直播吧
我说句可能你不太爱听的话
我们也经常说
在婚姻里边没有一个人是无辜的
大家理解吗
啊
欢迎大家
你有没有过这样的时候
一件小事
脑子里边翻来覆去想了一整晚
结果什么都没解决
反而更焦虑
其实
过度思考才是真正耗掉你能量的元凶
那么今天教给大家5个方法
帮你走出这么一个陷阱
第一个核查自己的想法
什么叫核查自己的想法
就是你的这个想法
会在脑海当中制造出一个情境
反映出你的不安全感和你的担忧
尤其是当你情绪很强烈的时候
我告诉你
很多想法其实并不真实的
所以你在接受他们之前
先核查一下事实
问一句这是事实还是我的脑补
这是真相还是我的演绎
那么这是第一点
第二点行动或放手
你问问自己
我现在能做点什么来改变过去
或者是积极影响未来吗
如果答案是能
那你就立刻行动
没问题那如果说答案是不能
那就心平
对吧那就心平气和的放手
要么做点事
要么顺其自然
剩下的自我折磨是没有任何意义的
很多人永远都是在烦恼
一些根本无法改变的事
第三点多想解决不了问题
大多数的问题
并不是靠想就能解决的
真正的答案
往往都是藏在沉默
时间和清醒的头脑里边
如果说你想了很久
还是没有答案
那我告诉你
别再想了
四个字交给时间
大家打出来
交给时间
时间不是解药
但解药都在时间里边
第4个减少自我拒绝
减少自我拒绝
你觉得你配不上那个机会
对吧你觉得文章不够好
你就发表
你觉得配不上那个机会
你就申请
你担心别人不回复你
你就发送
不要还没有开始
就先把自己给淘汰掉啊
第五记住问题很少是问题
什么意思呢
我跟大家说过
在心理学里边有一句话
99%的伤害都是来自于你的想法
只有1%的伤害才是来自于真正的结果
你们去品一品这句话
阿健也可以去品一品啊
好受多了是吧
嗯
那就好
原来是一直在看我们油管的同学是吧
啊欢迎欢迎啊
不断的看
不断的疗愈
我跟大家说过
有效的事重复做
无效的事停止做
就这么简单
哈哈你觉得对吧
听松明老师的这些影片也好
对吧我们的直播也好
能够让你疗愈
你就反复的听
开悟就是有一个过程
没有这种万箭穿心
哪来的刀枪不入啊
是吧
啊
所以很多时候
真正让你痛苦的不是这个问题的本身
而是你反复咀嚼问题的方式
所以别再让你的头脑成为
最大的敌人
过度的思考不会带来安全感的
只有你的行动和接纳才会
真正能够治愈你的
只有你的清醒和当下
所以
当你自己学会了
和这种过度思考拉开距离
你的心里边就会我觉得会轻松很多
是不是这样
但问题来了
你看很多人
他就是停不下来
很多的时候啊
你看有可能不是因为事儿太多
而是因为你的眼睛总是在盯着别人
对吧哎
他升职了
哈哈哎呀
他他怎么这么多的成就啊
哎呀这个人他有光环啊你看
那一不小心
我们就把别人的生活
当成了自己的考卷
但你要知道
就是你的人生
你真的要按他的剧本走吗
你确定吗
那我们接着来聊一聊
为什么别人的喧嚣
和你一点关系都没有
你有没有发现
我们总喜欢把别人的朋友圈
当成自己的人生考卷啊
我记得昨天还有一个同学
在我们直播间说
啊
为什么看到别人的朋友圈都那么好
看到别人升职买房环游世界
那你心里边肯定会涌上一些焦虑啊
为什么我还在原地踏步
但你要知道
第一
朋友圈永远都是别人的高光时刻
第二你永远无法复制
一段你不完全理解的人生
就是那些你羡慕的成功的故事
不过是别人精心挑选的高光时刻而已
你看到的只是光鲜亮丽的片段
但你看不到背后的压力
背后的牺牲
还有无数个独自崩溃的夜晚
不是每一条路都适合你走啊
也不是每一个成功都值得你羡慕
因为每个人的背景不
同好不好
资源也不同
起点不同
你的路径自然也不同啊
所以我想告诉你
你焦虑的真正的根源在哪
就是你总是在用别人的地图
来导航自己的人生
大家把这句话打出来用别人的地图
在导航自己的人生
那沟通课在我们的橱窗里边
可以点进去拍就可以了
可问题就在于
那张地图他并不属于你啊
真正的自由
不是盲目的模仿别人
而是你看清了所有的热闹和捷径之后
依然敢于坚定的
走在属于自己的夜路上
记住你看到的只是别人生活的切片
那不是真相
别人散出来的光环
对吧别人晒出来的光环
往往掩盖了他不愿意示人的脆弱
而你的生活
也无需拿去和别人比较
真正的成长
永远都是向内看
你不需要成为最卷的人
只需要比昨天的自己更清醒那么一点
更坚定一点
别人的喧嚣与你无关
把精力用来打磨自己
而不是观察别人
把时间花在走路上
而不是抬头看别人跑的有多快
当你学会专注自己
我告诉你
内耗会减少
脚步会更稳
你会慢慢的找到属于自己的节奏
也会明白
人生从来不是一场竞赛
而是一段独属于你的旅程
所以不要再活在别人的剧本里
别人的成功不是你的答案
你的答案只能在你的脚下生长啊
我不知道听完这一句话
有没有同学开始慢慢意识到
别人的热闹和你没关系
有的打一个三字来
有的打一个三字
有没有感觉到
有那么一丝丝的自由
感
有没有这种感觉
自由不等于彻底不受影响
在我们现在这个社会里边
对吧资讯满天飞
手机随时响的年代
你依然会刷到无数条信息
你依然会看到无数个对比和声音
对不对
就是你生活里边有很多的这种小沟子
一点点的在牵引你的情绪
那么我们如何来保护自己呢
在这么一个资讯繁杂的年代
那说的简单一点
答案就是把注意力收回来
怎么学会把注意力收回来
把专注力放在自己身上
所以我们打一句话
专注是最好的保护层
是什么的保护层
情绪
专注是情绪的保护层
怎么让自己心安呢
怎么让自己对吧
能够不再抑郁
不再焦虑啊
给了大家答案了吧
没有那么复杂吧
就两个字专注
他就是你的保护层
理解了吗
是不是啊嗯
你有没有发现
我们最累的时候
往往不是忙到崩溃
而是被外界的信息拉扯到心浮气躁啊
朋友圈里边的升职加薪
微博上的人生赢家
短视频里边的完美女孩
这些碎片化的高光时刻
就像无数双手在拽着你的情绪
他为什么比我瘦啊
哎呀他为什么比我赚那么多呀
他为什么
他们为对吧
他们为什么看起来毫不费力啊
于是很多人开始怀疑自己
焦虑空虚
自我否定
但你要明白
你看到的只是别人生活的切片
是他们挑选出来的广告
不是他们真正的真实啊
所以当你把注意力放在外界
你的情绪一定会被牵着走
但当你把注意力收回到自己的时候
你会突然感受到一种久违的平静
你会开始学会分辨
什么叫做热闹
什么叫做重要
什么叫做别人的表演
什么才是你的真实
那这一种专注感
就是一种情绪免疫力
就是一层保护你
免受外界浮躁侵扰的防护罩
所以你看
真正的情绪自由
不是彻底的屏蔽世界
而是拥有选择性专注的能力啊
你的注意力在哪
你的能量就在哪
当你把注意力从别人的舞台
收回到自己的生活
我相信你会发现
很多不必要的比较
自动就消散了
成长从来都不是比谁更热闹
而是比昨天的自己更清醒那么一点
更坚定一点
所以请允许自己不完美嘛
允许自己的生活有空白
有啥嘛不要被别人的喧嚣给裹挟
也别让外界的标准左右你的心
当你自己学会了专注自己
我告诉你
你就拥有了
抵御浮躁世界的情绪免疫力
这个才是最稳固的保护层啊
所以我跟大家经常说
注意力把所有的专注力给自己
就是最好的爱自己
那嗯
当你自己能够把这个注意力拉回来
我相信你会慢慢的懂得
永远这种情绪的自由
就是来自于你的专注
对吧
但情绪的安定
只是第一步
一个人要真正的成长
其实有时候还需要更加深层次的专注
不是为了躲开比较
而是为了你能够看到
自己一点一滴的这么一个进步
所以真正的成长
不是比别人快
我们刚刚说了
是比昨天的自己更清晰
更坚定
是不是啊
我们接着来
聊一聊
专注和成长到底是一个什么样的关系
啊今天讲的内容大家能跟上来吗啊
觉得有收获的咱们打一波7字来
那欢迎大家来到我们的这么一个啊
聊聊心理学
每天早上
聊聊心理学的这么一个直播间啊
如果觉得很受用
或者是在这待的很舒服的同学
不要忘了加加松明老师的关注
大家可以点一点订阅啊
我们频道的订阅
然后可以加一加
咱们的这么一个粉丝团
啊如果你错过了前面的内容
没有关系
你也可以加入
我们频道的这么一个会员
点击宋明老师的头像
点击会员
然后每一周我们都会有直播的回放
会放到我们的会员专区里边啊
欢迎大家
太有收获是吧
老师我来晚了
刚刚好啊
我觉得刚刚好啊
我喜欢这两个数字是吧
那就好啊
对我看到好多同学
没有没有亮灯牌的同学
大家把灯牌可以帮我亮一亮吗
啊感谢谢啊
谢谢各位
对不知道怎么亮灯牌的同学有吗
需要我来教一教吗
第一个点击关注
点完关注以后呢
然后点那个什么小红心小黄心的啊
就可以把灯牌亮起来了
哎金丝雨啊
欢迎恭喜啊
恭喜我们的啦
买过老师的课啊
买的什么课呀
啊看的什么课呀
嗯
对我们接着聊一聊这个
专注和成长的关系啊
欢迎各位
很多人会认为成长就是和别人比
比成绩比收入对吧
比谁跑得更快
但事实上
我告诉大家
真正的成长从
来不是在喧嚣里发生的
允许自己不完美
允许自己生活有空白
这个才是成长最真实的样子
就是你变强的时刻
往往都不是站在领奖台上
被掌声包围的这么一个高光时刻
而是在无人问津的深夜
你独自对话
默默坚持
当你困惑
却仍然选择再走一步
那一份平凡的积累
才是你和别人真正拉开差距的地方
我跟大家说过
人活到最后就一个人
就是我们永远都要学会一个东西
怎么样去面对自己的孤独
我跟你说
你如果说如果说
你学会了面度啊
如果说你学会了面对孤独
你就已经有了一张底牌
你不会差到哪去
大不了一个人呗
是不是
所以成长从来是不靠比较的
而是靠深度
是靠那些看似孤独的坚持
让你比昨天更清晰一点
比昨天更坚定一点
所以我觉得
你不需要成为最卷的人
你只需要把精力放在打磨自己
而不是观察别人
对吧看别人走得快
容易让你焦虑
可专注在自己的身上
才能让你稳稳的向前走啊
所以记住
你想要的未来
不会在比较中发芽
只会在专注里边扎根
别再把力气浪费在羡慕或者嫉妒
也不要因为不完美就苛责自己
真正的成长
是在一次次的自我和解里边
逐渐找到自己方向的
当你学会接纳不确定
学会允许自己慢一点
笨一点你会发现
生活其实并不催你
真正催你的人
一直是你自己
所以还是那么一句话
别和别人比
只和昨天的自己比
当你能踏实的走好
每一步
未来就已经在悄悄的靠近你了
所以你看
成长的这么一个过程
永远都是一个人和自己的对话
大家把这句话打一打
成长就是和自己的对话
来我们把这句话打出来
成长是和自己的对话
我我想问大家一个问题
你们觉得
就是人际关系给你带来的困扰
在你的生活里边儿占有百分之多少呀
大家打在评论区我看一看
来
你们觉得人际关系给你们带来的困扰
你们觉得是可以占到百分之多少
嗯
学会孤独好难
我总觉得我要有一个异性的陪伴
哪怕不见面
只是打电话
对你这个叫寂寞
孤独是不需要人陪
嫉妒是一定要人陪
孤独和寂寞不一样
寂寞是遭遇的本质
孤独是一种淡然的气质
啊 6%
百分之七八十
10%
啊这都是活通透的同学
哈哈啊
你们觉得
人际关系对给你们带来的困扰有多少
90%啊
三十六十啊
二十七十
更少一点
很少是多少
每个人对很少的定义都不太一样 60
嗯
60 是吧
从来了宋明老师
这变成0了
没有困扰了是吧
不会拍领导马屁
为什么你会觉得拍领导马屁很重要呢
啊
比拍领导马屁更重要的
是你自己的价值啊
你的不可被去代替代性啊
听到老师的课越来越少是吧
OK我知道
但你知道生活不是独角戏吗
你终究我跟大家说过三个关系
第一个是你和自己的关系
第一段关系不是人际关系
对吧
第二段关系才是人际关系
第三段关系是你和这个
世界的关系
你怎么和这个世界连接啊
很多人说
最大的难题不是自己不够努力
但是就是和人的沟通总是卡壳
说多了呢
对吧刚刚有同学说
怕得罪领导
沉默了呢
又怕被忽视
是不是这样
那有没有一种方法
能够让沟通变得简单呢
啊其实有
我给大家说这么一句话
可能会解决很多的沟通的一些难题
啊一句话解决所有沟通难题
听到这你可能觉得不可思议
沟通这事
怎么可能有100%的方法呢
其实不仅有
而且很简单
只是你做不到而已
哈哈哈什么方法呢
啊一句话就讲完了
听他说什么
不要去管他怎么说
这句话大家能理解吗
啊可以打一打
听他说什么
不要管他怎么说
这句话大家是一个什么样的感觉
听他说什么
不要管他怎么说
但现实里边
大部分人都做反了
我们很少真正听人说什么
但是我们特别在意别人怎么说
你有没有发现
明明对方讲的有道理
但只要语气不好
态度冷漠
你就会立刻的不接受
甚至还会搞一句
你怎么可以这样跟我讲话呀
你看
这就是我们沟通里边最大的毛病
太在乎语气和形式
但忽略了内容和道理
所以说如果说
你能做到
不管对方态度好不好
对吧声音好不好听
甚至他心里边是不是带着情绪
你都先放下这些
只听他说的内容
只看这句话有没有道理
所以当你能这样做
你会发现
很多矛盾其实不需要吵架
很多的误会也根本不需要解释
因为你听懂
了他真正想表达的东西
沟通不是斗气
沟通的本质是理解
所以你学会这一点
你就会发现
无论夫妻也好
亲子也好
还是你的职场也好
冲突会少一半
关系会顺畅很多
所以
记住100%有效的沟通秘诀听他说什么
别管他怎么说
有收获的打一个7字来
啊有收获的同学
打一个7字
你去试一试嘛
有效果你就坚持做
没效果你就不做
很简单
是不是这么一个道理啊同学们
啊
我们有专门的一套沟通课程
很好的 30多节课啊
不是30多节课
是30节课啊
沟通的核心在什么
沟通的核心在于关系
大家理解吗
关系好了
有效沟通
关系不好
无效沟通
是吧
最沟通的秘诀
就是学会真正的倾听
倾听
我跟大家说
有五个维度嘛
语言背后的需求
需求背后的情绪
情绪背后的期待
期待背后的渴望
渴望背后的防御
其实这就是倾听
啊
是吧但你也会发现
其实并不是所有人
都值得你花心思去沟通
我跟大家说过
善良给对人
在这个年代
我跟你们说
善良是很稀缺的东西了
来我们一边点赞一边听来
我看好多同学点赞
今天点赞的数量
数字比较少啊
大家动动你们的小手
帮宋明老师点点赞
来点点赞来
啊善良给对人
对吧付出是好的
但咱们的付出要给对关系
你明明碰到一只白眼狼
你还把你的付出扔进去
你明知道这个关系是个泥潭
是个黑洞
你还要把这个东西扔进去
那不是别人的问题啊
对吧
慈悲
是美的
给那些敬畏你的人
他如果对你没有这种敬畏心
我告诉你
你就不要管
真的啊
所以你这个人还是要有一个边界
大家理解吗
你可以学一些沟通的技术
但是要挑人
如果你碰到了一个吸血鬼
我跟你说
你就是个神仙
你都拉不起来他就怎么样
就这么简单啊
哼对方是一个话痨
喋喋不休就麻烦了
那你让他说个够
你把你的耳朵藏起来
左耳进右耳出
很简单啊
是吧
我跟你说
有些人你越沟通
你越觉得被消耗
有没有这样感觉的同学
有的打一来
是不是这样啊
所以我跟你们说
不是所有人都值得你花心思去沟通的
那些斤斤计较的人
你试试你跟他沟通试一试
那个处处算计你的人
你跟他沟通试一试
遇到吸血鬼怎么办
遇到吸血鬼
让他滚出你的生活
你多看他一眼就算你输
真的
人心不足蛇吞象啊
同学们
啊
对吧
沟通可以解决问题
但朋友呢
就是你要做选择的
就是要不要深交啊
取决于对方的人品
对吧
那人品不好的
你怎么沟通都没用
特别是比较抠的人
能理解吗
啊永远不要和抠的人做朋友哈哈哈
在人生的路上
你会遇到各种各样的人
但有一种人你一定要远离
就是抠的人
我说的抠不是节俭呐
节俭的人
他是懂得合理安排嘛
他懂得珍惜资源嘛
往往是温和
是靠谱的
抠的人不一样
抠代表着心机
代表着算计
甚至是阴暗
你会发现
你和抠的人相处
总有一种透不过
气的感觉有没有
你吃个饭他也要斤斤计较
合作的时候
他就想着多占你的便宜
哪怕是朋友的情谊
他也要衡量能不能从你身上榨点啥
就在他的逻辑里边
不亏就等于赚
所以
他们可以花很多的心思去算计一块钱
却从来不会花一点真心去对待一个人
那你和这样的人在一块
我跟你说
你得不到滋养的
你只会被消耗
你会开始真正的怀疑友情
甚至你都会怀疑自己啊
所以真正值得交往的朋友
不是看他有没有钱
而是看他有没有格局
一个大方的人
哪怕他没有多少财富
也能够让你感受到舒心和自在
一个抠的人
我跟你说
哪怕他再有钱
你也只会感受到他的冷漠和这种压力
所以记住
交朋友不要看表面
看心胸
远离抠的人
才能为自己留下更多的温暖
和真诚的空间
人生永远不怕朋友少
就怕朋友错
选择远离抠门
其实就是在选择一种更舒适
更有价值的人生啊
是不是这么一个道理啊
同学们啊
虽然这话不好听啊
虽然这话不好听
但是也可以听一听啊
是不是可以停一停
有同学说
你看我和老公10天没说话
真的是没法沟通
所以朋友如此
伴侣更是如此
哈哈
就是你人生的路上
你选择什么样的人同行
一定会决定你过什么样的生活
友情靠坦荡
爱情靠真心
你也许会问
那两个人在一块相处
那最理想的这个境界到底是什么呀
是这种宠爱呢
还是这种理解呢
还是这种守护呢你告诉我
那我跟你说
答案比你想的更深
我们来聊一聊两性关系的最高境界
好不好
那我说简单一点啊
两性关系的最高境界是什么
不是轰轰烈烈
而是彼此懂得
女人爱男人
对吧极致的交付就是身体嘛
男人爱女人呢
极致的就是袒露自己的灵魂
女人想懂男人
你就去听他酒后的沉默
男人想懂女人
你就看他崩溃时的眼泪
女人的疼爱
是包容她的倔强而男人的宠爱
是纵容她的小心
女人的信任
要看他低谷时候的担当男人的信任
要看他繁华时的坚守啊
女人的温暖
我觉得是深夜的一盏灯
男人的温暖呢
是风里边的一堵墙
女人的陪伴
是熬过低谷的耐心男人的陪伴
是笑对平淡的真心
女人的懂
从理解压力开始男人的懂
在情绪里起步
女人的敬重
是因为对方有责任
男人的敬重
是因为对方有温柔
女人的爱
藏在三餐四季里
而男人的爱
融在柴米油盐中
女人示弱是信任男人服软是深爱
女人欣赏男人
始于才华
忠于人品
男人欣赏女人
始于颜值
陷于温柔
所以最美的爱情
不是你追我逃
而是灵魂的共鸣
岁月的守护
女人懂男人的累
会递上一杯热茶男人懂女人的苦
会说一句贴心的话
真正的爱
是彼此成就
各自闪耀
在平凡中
相互看见
彼此懂得
那我也愿所有有情人
都能够以爱为帆
以懂为舵
在岁月里边共赴星辰大海
因为爱从来都不是单向奔赴
而是双向的共鸣
那如果错
过我们今天直播的同学啊
不要忘了可以加加咱们的会员啊
会员里边是有直播回放的啊
你们也不要今天在直播间跟我说
宋明老师
你再讲一遍啊
你不要说我会读心啊
哈哈哈好不好
觉得有收获的来咱们打一波
三来
余生很贵
请别浪费
说得好啊
点击头像
点击头像啊
点击会员就可以了
哈哈
恭喜小鱼儿啊
成为我们的会
嗯会员
所以你看
两性关系里边很多矛盾
矛盾的这么一个根源
其实是讨好
和讨好有关啊
就是你一味想满足对方
对吧但是你又想维持这个自我
结果呢常常两头都不讨好
是不是这样啊
其实不仅是爱情
我跟你说
你看看在你的职场啊
在你的友情
在你的家庭里边
我们也常常如此
你以为是善良
其实是内耗
那内耗的真相到底是什么
我们接着来看一看好不好
内耗的真相就是想两边讨好
大家把这句话打一打
不知道怎么加我们会员的同学
我再跟大家说一说
简单的说一说
首先点击宋明老师的头像来
点击头像以后
你们会看到有一个会员啊
然后点进去对吧
啊
然后加入就可以了
嗯
跟宋明老师在直播间是一种享受
是吧哈哈哈
欢迎大家啊
没有加关注的大家加一下关注来
你看
很多人的内耗都是来自于这个地方
大家想想是不是这么一个道理啊
你的内耗是不是来自于两边想讨好啊
没有那么复杂对不对
你有没有这样吗
啊
就你有没有过这样的时
刻嘛上班的时候呢
担心老板的眼神和他的态度
和同事聊天呢
怕一句话说错被误解
下班陪朋友呢
又怕自己表现的不够贴心
回到家里边呢
你还要揣着
对吧你还要揣摩家里人的情绪
和他们的评价
就是你的一天
你看起来啥都做了
可你的心从头到尾都没在自己身上
所谓内耗
就是这么一点一点积累起来的
真正让人累的
往往不是工作
也不是社交
而是你总想两边都讨好
却一次次忽略了自己啊
你是不是常常去纠结我是不是没做好
我是不是说错话了
我是不是让别人失望了
那我告诉你
这种不断的自我怀疑
就像是在给自己交一笔心理税
没有人强迫你付
却让你消耗殆尽
可是你要明白
没有人能够给你情绪管理费的
你的人生
也不该成为别人的期待和情绪的容器
所以成熟不是学会迎合
而是学会选择
来这句话打一打
成熟不是学会迎合
而是学会选择
真正的成熟
是你要关掉那些没必要的窗口
把注意力拉回到自己身上
你不必对所有人负责
你只需要对真正重要的人
以及你自己负责
所以专注你自己
不是冷漠
而是你终得
而是你终于懂得分清界限
什么该在乎
什么可以放下
对吧谁值得付出
谁无需讨好
当你不再活在别人的眼神里边
你的心才会真正的轻松啊
你会发现
这个世界并没有因为你说不而崩塌
反而因为你更清醒
关系变得更简单
生活变得更自由
所以记住内
耗不是来自于外界
而是你总是在和自己较劲
当你如果学会把注意力收回来
学会对无关的人和事说no
你才真正的开始为自己活一次
所以
别再把精力浪费在取悦别人身上了
真正的成熟
就是敢于拒绝
敢于专注
敢于对自己说我不需要所有人喜欢
我只需要忠于自己
当你明白这些内耗的根源
你会发现
真正的解药
不是让所有人满意
而是让自己清晰
对吧清晰带来方向
方向就会带来一个东西
叫做自律
可这里的自律
不是说让你去盲目的模仿别人
而是说你要找到属于自己的节奏
我记得我们上次聊过对吧
一个中年男人
一个中年的对吧
一个心理学博主啊
就是我自己啊
最重要的就是四个字叫找回节奏
那我们聊一聊
什么叫自律啊
什么叫找回节奏
那
真正的自律
就是守住自己的节奏
你看很多人一提到自律
脑子里边立刻浮现的就是早点
我要对吧
早上我要5点起床
每周我要看3本书
每天高效打卡10件事儿
好像不这样就不叫自律
但我告诉你事实是什么
真正的自律
不是模仿别人
而是守住属于自己的节奏
你不必每天都完美的执行这些计划
也不必在每一个方面都要赢过别人
你需要的
是稳定长期
舒服的走在自己的节奏里边
每天睡够觉
对吧吃好饭
适度运动
读一点喜欢的书
看一看喜欢的课
这些看似平凡的小习惯
正在悄悄搭建你的生活系统啊
别人的高强度也
许并不适合你
而你自己的慢节奏
也并不等于懒惰
自律的关键不在于快
而在于能否持续
很多人容易陷入到一个误区
就是把自己的速度和别人的速度比
别人跑得快
就觉得自己落后
别人做的多
你就怀疑自己不够好
但是你忘了
你不是在跑别人的人生
你是在走自己的路
真正的成长
不在于你跑多快
而是在于你能不能坚持往前
哪怕每天只进步one PERCENT
长期坚持下去
依然会有惊人的累积效应
所以
不要再强迫自己去复制别人的清单
删除那些我必须要像谁一样的念头
找到自己能够长期坚持的最小版本
然后对自己说
按我这样的速度坚持下去就够了
所以节奏的意义从来不在于快慢
而是在于是否让你感到踏实和自在
记住
真正的自律不是把自己卷到精疲力尽
而是要找到属于你自己的节奏
并忠实的去守护它
如果说当你活在了自己的节奏里边
你会发现生活没有那么难
你的焦虑也会慢慢的消散
因为你终于学会了不和别人比
只和自己比
当你能够守住自己的节奏
你会慢慢的放下这些焦虑啊同学们
对吧
虽然在生活里边总有人跑得比你快
买房比你早
事业比你顺
你要如何安放这种差距感呢
别人的快不等于你的慢
大家理解吗
这句话
你们可以把这句话打一打
别人的快不等于你的慢
怎么去理解这句话啊
因为每个人的路不一样
对吧每
一步都有独特的价值啊
这个价值只有你自己知道啊
那我们怎么去安心走自己的路呢
我们来聊一聊
别人的快不等于你的慢
我不知道你有没有这样的时刻
明明知道自己也在努力
按照计划一步步的往前走
可是只要看到别人跑得快
你就心就突然慌了
对吧同事跳槽涨薪水
朋友晒出新的成就
短视频里边满屏的成功案例
你就会忍不住质疑
是不是我自己落后了呀
是不是我自己做的不够好啊
但其实真正的稳定感
从来都不是外界给的
而是来自你内心的那一句
我知道我在做什么
来我们把这句话打出来
当你清楚的知道自己的目标
知道此刻正在积累什么
明白这一步走的慢
没关系因为我告诉你
它就是通往下一步的必经之路
你的心不会被轻易的动摇
所以稳定感不等于风平浪静
而是你知道你的船往哪开
外界的风吹草动
没关系因为你始终知道
你始终清楚自己在做什么
别人涨薪升职
你知道自己正处在打基础的阶段
别人看似在走捷径
你知道你的路正在慢慢的铺开
这种底气
我跟你说
不会凭空出现的
它一定是来自于你每一天
小小的这么一个坚持
完成计划里边的那一件事
推进手里边正在做的工作
在节奏里边找回属于自己的步伐
当你一次次校准方向
一次次确认我有在走路
你的大脑就会给你一个自然的回馈
我在往前走
我没有迷路
这个就是稳定感最宝贵的来源
不是别人的一句安慰啊
而是你在参与自己人生的时候
一点一滴积累起来的底气
所以大家记住一句话
节奏没有对错
快的人咱们有快的精彩
慢的人有慢的厚度啊
关键不在速度
而是在于
你是不是走在属于自己的路上
所以真正的稳定感
来自对自己的了解
来自那种我知道我在做什么的笃定
所以你不要再去焦虑别人的奔跑
把注意力收回来
专注在脚下的每一步
当你清楚自己要去哪
我跟你说
你就已经比大多数人更稳定了
也更接近你想要的未来了
人生
从来不是一场和别人拼速度的赛跑
而是一段和自己并肩同行的旅程啊
你会遇到比较
你会有内耗
会被别人的眼神和声音拉扯
可真正让你能走的稳的
可真正能够让你走的稳的
不是外界的掌声
是你自己的内心的坚定
我知道我在做什么
我知道我往哪走
所以别再为浪费时间去讨好所有人
也别因为别人的快而否定自己
成长就是把注意力收回来
守住自己的节奏
哪怕很慢
也依然坚定
那我也愿大家在往后的日子里边
少一点焦虑
多一点清醒
在自己的路上走的稳走的远